[Música]
es uno de los mayores problemas tiene
que ver con la pandemia tenemos
trabajadores esenciales a la vanguardia
en nuestro país son la columna vertebral
de la nación pero la disparidad en la
atención es muy clara latinos y
comunidades negras son las más afectadas
por esta pandemia y joe biden quiere
ampliar la ley de atención médica
asequible es el presidente que
necesitamos
equipo
creo que mucha gente realmente le gusta
donald trump no lo dicen de forma
pública pero veo muchas señales creo que
la tendencia va en su dirección creo que
hay mucha emoción en su candidatura
creo que con el bloqueo con el
coronavirus creo que eso realmente le
ayudo por aquí estamos un poco
frustrados con el encierro
estoy debutaron
[Música]
votaré por yo white en en noviembre
porque creo que es la hora de un cambio
creo que nuestras comunidades merecen
algo mejor mis padres son inmigrantes
mexicanos no son violadores y no son
narcotraficantes en realidad trabajaron
muy duro durante toda la pandemia son
trabajadores esenciales y creo que
nuestras comunidades merecen algo mejor
[Música]
para mí lo ha hecho bien ahora hay un
relato detrás de su figura llevo aquí
casi 17 años vengo de puerto rico y lo
que veo aquí es a los demócratas siempre
sabes a qué me refiero si ingresas
cuando que ves aquí destrucción de
calles y de lo que sea sabes a qué me
refiero corrupción robos
parece que el presidente de trump va a
nominar a una mujer que irá contra todo
lo que represento ruth báder ginsburg y
esto demuestra lo falsa que es la
política republicana y lo cínica que es
frente a un icono que tuvo principios y
trabajo hasta el día de su muerte
[Música]
y siento que es realmente importante que
el presidente de trump impulse a un
nominado para la corte suprema y sea
alguien que crea en la vida crea en la
constitución crea en la libertad y crea
en la justicia y creo que trump es
definitivamente el artífice de que eso
suceda
a veces la quimioterapia es necesaria
para el cáncer
trump es quimioterapia estas personas
son socialistas comunistas pedazos de
excrementos inútiles aceptaremos lo que
venga de trump es mejor un idiota que un
comunista baile no sería mi candidato
ideal probablemente pero al menos no es
donald tsonga no sé qué tan sincera se
me permite ser pero creo que donald
trump no es una buena persona lo que
respecta a cuestiones sociales y de
otros tenemos familiares que pueden
votar y a menudo a veces no están tan
comprometidos pero nosotros hacemos la
tarea ya sabes somos nosotros los que
queremos impulsar el botín
cuando era niño me educaron para ser
demócrata mamá y papá siempre me decían
que tenía que ser del partido porque
representaban al trabajador y al
agricultor pero ahora mismo no es así
[Música]